We got a walk-in.
A defector.
He's Russian.
Neuroscan is up.
Ev.
What's your name?
My name is Vassily Orlov.
Nothing.
He doesn't exist.
Today, a Russian agent will travel to New York City...
...to kill the President.
This agent is KA12.
The KA Program is a myth.
Scan says he's truthful.
This guy is selling smoke.
Wrap it up, Ev.
Don't you want to know the name?
You're good!
You can tell the rest of your story to one of my colleagues.
The name of the agent is Evelyn Salt.
My name is Evelyn Salt.
Then you are a Russian spy.
Where'd she go?
What are you doing, Ev?
This doesn't look good.
I'm not a Russian spy.
On the ground!
I'm innocent.
Somebody's setting me up.
Salt, no!
Maybe Salt is who she says she is.
"Maybe" is your department.
Mine is catching her so we can find out.
Drop it!